Alex and Marcus Louis welcome.
[inaudible] Alex, when you were 18 years old, you have this accident,
a motorcycle accident. Uh, and when you woke up from that,
all you could remember was your brother, your twin brother Mark.
Yeah, my first memory, I guess,
in my whole life was waking up and just seeing his face and just saying hello,
Marcus to him. And at that point, I just thought everything was fine.
I'd been in a coma for about six weeks from a motorbike crash.
And so I was very disorientated. I didn't know what was happening.
And I saw him, I knew his name, I thought fine.
Can you, can you try to describe that bond, that, that bond between you as,
as identical twins.
It's kind of a, it's a, um, a non bike-able bond. We would describe it as, um,
as identical twins. Everybody works on a hundred percent, right?
We reckon the identical twins work on 110%. So we work inside that 10%.
And that's the difference?
Um, the thing is that this, um,
this gave you a,
an enormous responsibility because you were the one that had to recreate his
memories in a way and, and,
and teach him everything again. Yeah. So.
He woke up, he didn't know, um, anything that was going on around him.
He didn't know who am I, who our mother was. And though she was there.
So my mother came to the bed. So he woke up and said, hello, Marcus, or Marcie,
as he used to call us in the old days.
And then my mother came up and then he started getting very excited.
And he said, who is this woman? And I said,
but this is our mum. And he said, I don't know who she is. She needs to go away.
Cause she's freaking me out. But he knew exactly who I was and he knew my name.
So that's when I realized that he had got zero apart from one fact,
which was me.
But does that mean he couldn't do normal things like that?
He started off, um, in a mental age of about six or seven.
Um, so he didn't know what a hospital was. He didn't know what a bed was.
He'd never seen a cat in an animal house, nothing.
So he had to start from zero ground, zero ground, zero shoe laces,
brushing your teeth, simple stuff. So that start again.
So we started that process. When he came out of the hospital,
we started that process slowly. How.
How did he go about, well.
You know, we're quite old now. So back in those days,
there was no aftercare and the national health, it was see you later,
he was awake and we went home. And so we had no professional help.
And my mother was refusing to believe that she did, he did lost his memory.
So it was just me on my own. I was 18 years old. So we just,
he just only stuck to me. And so I just had to explain, you know,
this is our house, this is our, this is our room.
This is how you brush your teeth. This is how you choose, you know,
that was the easy stuff.
And then we went through the house and then he understood what everything was
going on. And then eventually we got into more difficult stuff.
Like this is your girlfriend. Um, yeah,
we got past the easy stuff pretty quickly.
And then go to the more complicated stuff. Yeah.
But, but, but it's because you, you take us to that house,
the house that you came back to, it didn't recognize, never, never seen before.
Um, what kind of hope.
It was really daunting. It was enormous house.
Our parents lived in a very grand English Manor house and it's,
I have lots of wings. It was enormous thing. And it was just very daunting.
It was quite, the whole thing was very scary. I was very shy.
I didn't really say much. I cried a lot. I was basically a kid in an adult body.
And, um, your mother described, how, how was she, what kind of woman?
She was a, she was, she was a, an English debutante,
high society lady. She was the center of any party.
Everybody knew who she was when she came in the room.
You definitely knew she had arrived very loud. So you know,
an amazing presence. And she just could not,
or would not accept that her son did not know her.
What about your stepdad? Because he was also there.
Yeah. My stepdad was, um, he was a difficult character. He was, um,
uh, you know,
he was quite a powerful man in his field and he was not a particularly nice man.
Um, he didn't really take to us very much. So he was, he was quite cool.
Yeah. So he, he never came to the hospital for instance. Um, so he never.
There were quite strict rules that were normal to you,
but really normal. Yeah. We, um, we.
We moved out to the shed when we were 14.
We weren't allowed to live in the house. We lived in a shed in the garden,
a basic shed, no heating, no nothing, just lights. And we're talking about, um,
he didn't want you in the house and we're talking about a nine bedroom house
with huge grounds that we used to open to the public in the summer, you know,
proper grand house in England.
And we lived in the shed because we weren't his kids and he
felt he didn't want, you know, he just didn't want us in the house.
It was easier just to get rid of us. So, you know, we lived out there. We, we,
we quite like living out there cause it was a lot easier.
This was what you had to, to bring him back to yes.
This life and, and so far so good, I guess. Uh,
but the whole truth about what had happened before he
lost his memory that was revealed after your mother's death, right?
Yeah.
Yes. Yeah. For me, everything was normal.
I got the life I had from 18 to 32.
I lived the fantasy life that my brother gave me. I lived in that world.
I didn't know any different. My parents were fantastic people. They were lovely.
We had a lovely childhood. Everything was fairy tale.
Maybe he gave me a fairy tale book and I lived it from 18 to 32.
And when I didn't ask questions, now it was basic questions.
I asked basic questions, but it was normal for me.
I didn't have any reason to ask questions. So it was, it all seemed in place.
And I look back on it now and I just can't believe I didn't try it when dad
died. So he died when we were 25,
25, you can tell it. Yeah. He died when we were 25.
And he was very, very difficult man, very cruel man. And he asked,
he was on his death bed and he came, he came to us and he said,
I want you both to forgive me for the way I've treated you, your whole life,
I'm going to die. And I wanted to go to heaven.
He suddenly became religious and he wasn't religious.
He became religious in the last four days. And
will you forgive me and moccasins? And I was like, yes, of course,
I'll forgive you. You know, you can go in peace. And [inaudible] said, no,
you can die.
I'm not giving you forgiveness and walked out of the room two days later,
he's dead. And I was like,
that was the first time that Marcus and I had ever had it.
Problem. But when your mother died, uh, what did you think then?
Did you think that now he will learn the truth? Now it will.
Everything will be revealed.
No, I didn't. I just felt that, you know, now she's gone. Um,
I can live my life in a much easier way, so I don't have to deal with her.
And I was never going to tell Alex ever what happened because he'd been,
he'd been left with this nice, happy childhood that I created for him.
So it gave me a sense of relief from the childhood that we had had. Um,
so it was a, so he was of doing himself.
He was doing me a favor by giving me his gift, but he was also gifting himself.
But it was a double thing. How was it revealed to you? How did it feel?
So when our mother died, that was the moment I realized everything.
Wasn't right. Because how can it cost? Cause nobody cried.
No one cried about as our sisters, no one cried. I was the only one crying.
She just died. And I suddenly thought, Whoa, Whoa, hang on a sec.
What is happening here? And that's,
I started thinking and it really troubled me. So I started working,
looking at things and asking more questions. And then we started. So then we,
then we started cleaning out the house. Um,
and then we started finding strange things in the house,
which Alex was struggling to accept.
So we found lots of odd things and sex toys and some,
some weird stuff going on and I'm starting to get more and most sort of freaked
out by it. When our, all our birthday presents, we found in the loft,
every person that we never given to us, biological parents, grandparents,
everything hard with mobile. You never saw the gifts, never saw the gifts,
stole all the money is still in the envelopes. One pound, two pounds.
Amazing. If you never gave them to us all still there. So we found all of that,
which was kind of quite strange. And that was really strange. And then,
and then we opened up this, um, the back of the cupboard,
there was another little small cupboard inside and we went inside there and
I can't remember which one of us did it,
but we basically opened this drawer and there was a photograph in there of us to
age 10 naked with our heads cut off.
And now my whole world has just changed in an instant.
So, so sorry, the heads, the heads were cut off.
Of the picture and now I'm thinking, Whoa,
this lady is way more complicated than I have been led to believe who the hell
is she? And what is this about? And that's when we started.
Did you, did you confront your brother directly? Yeah.
Yeah. So after a little while I would switch,
I had to get some therapy just to deal with that and then sorted that out.
And then I chose challenge markers and I literally just challenged them with
simple words. Where are we abused by our mother or not?
And what did you answer?
I didn't, I just nodded, he just nodded. It was just, it's a moment.
Because your, your world fell apart in a way also.
Everything, you know, you have a choice in life. You can decide to tell a lie,
which is quite a big thing to do to your brother. Um,
or given the truth. So for me,
I created a life for both of us. Are you angry? Really angry?
Yeah. Yeah. Really bad.
I mean, he, he didn't want to say anymore, right?
Couldn't say anymore. Cause he, the game was up. He'd been caught out.
The live was over. I was furious. The one person I trusted in my entire life,
the only person I trusted had lied to me and had been lying for
over a decade. At that moment, I was on my own.
And for the first time in your life, first time in my life, I was on my own.
And I just didn't know how I didn't have any emotions or, or,
or know how to get to the next stage.
But did you, did you want to know more? Did you want to find out everything?
How long did it take?
So it took me, it took me from the,
from the age of 32 to 50.
So 20 years, 20 years of obsessively, trying to work out who I was.
And you didn't say anything for 20 years, you wouldn't.
I gave him the bare bones. Um, I'd kind of like,
I kind of told him that we would have been abused by a lover and that was really
all he needed to know.
How was the relationship between you? We wear those.
When we went back to a hundred percent minus fraternal soap. Yes.
That's the thing. So we got back together. I was very angry with him,
obviously for awhile, but within a few short, well, when we say a while,
a few months, a few months, I mean, were twins.
People would take years to do that. We did that in a few months, even a story,
as big as that.
In a way you accepted that, he didn't want to talk about it. Yeah. What, what,
what do you know today? So I learned.
A lot more that we were definitely,
our mother was a serial pedophile and she used all her own children to do
that with, um, for her own gratification.
And she then went on to handing her children out. She ran a ring,
Peter fire ring, and she used her children to supply that ring for,
she was a very wealthy individual. We can't think it was for money.
We'd have no idea what the motivation of all that was, but that's what she did.
So we were abused by her friends, men.
So this, this was, this became a part of her social life.
Came a part of her social life. She would deliver us to someone's house, have,
have drinks, have a glass of wine near us there.
And you, you just know this, you remember?
Yeah, for me, it's a story for him. It's real. I mean, I,
I had no intention of really telling Alex the whole thing. Um,
and then in the documentary that we made, I had,
we'd been doing that shooting for 10 days and we'd got to know the director for
five years before, before we started shooting,
he spent five years getting us on the side. Then when he was doing the shooting,
he kept asking me, so what really happened? What really happened?
And he's a very good director. And he just kept asking me and I kept saying,
well, why do you want to know? And then something snapped to me.
And I just said like, I'm going to tell you.
So I told him straight to camera and he asked me the next
day, whether I could do it again for Alex. And I said, I couldn't do that.
Okay. W when did you realize that that's not normal?
I was 14 years old. I was in, uh, in London in a,
in a strange guy's house. Uh, he was, uh,
quite a famous artist and I was in his four poster bed and he
started talking. It was just you, not your mother. She was not there. No.
Cause my mother, she never took us together.
She only took us her own and she would always leave.
And so I said, no, I don't want you to do this to me.
I don't like this.
Something snapped. Tell him, yeah, I was 14.
I was a bit bigger. Know I was a teenager. And I just said, no,
this is not acceptable. Don't do this.
And he got very aggressive and I managed to get out of his room. Um,
I managed to get out of his house. Um, I got into the street,
I got down to the chief station.
And in those days you could jump on the tube for free.
So I jumped over the thing.
So I got back to our village and I walked home and I got back into bed
in our room.
And I woke up in the morning and I came out for breakfast and my mum was super
shocked to see me. I looked at her, she looked at me and I went like that.
And she knew that it was done as in no one's touching us.
Did she stop as well then? Yes. I mean, everything stopped.
Yeah. She knew that, that, that was the end. Yeah. We didn't speak about it.
I just gave her a look as to say, this is over.
Could you, I mean, you shared a room, you, you,
you spent a lot of time together. Could you talk about that then? No.
I mean, not, I don't believe that any abuse kids talk about it, we don't do it.
And the thing that we all do is silence.
All people who get sexually abused,
who are watching this show know that the biggest power that they have is
fear and silence. And we're here during break it out.
[Inaudible] it's um, uh,
the fact is, I mean, this, this story is,
has affected so many people, uh, and it's been, uh, it's been, uh,
like 70 countries, uh, all over the world. Uh,
people have been watching this and, uh, this documentary that you made.
Um, and I, I guess I know that for you, it's,
it's not really a story about Peter files.
No, I don't think we've made a movie about sexual abuse.
Aren't we don't feel that we've done that. We feel it's a love story.
It's a love story between two brothers and it's about our life.
And it's about how twins operate.
And it's about a life that happens to be a part of it.
But th because at first you were angry about the lies, but can you today,
can you see that was,
this fantasy was built out of some kind of love.
It was a gift, but he gave me was a gift and I can only see it only in one way.
And we joke about it. And he says, he gave me,
he gave me a free pass and he got a free pass and he didn't have a fridge.
[Inaudible] would you wish that you never got to know?
Uh, no.
So I think as you get more mature and you get older and you have children,
you have your own family then to, to be denied all of that information.
I just don't think I could handle that. So, yes,
I didn't want that information when I was 20.
I couldn't have handled it all authority. If so, to have it later on in life,
I could intellectualize it and deal with it.
So we're closer now than we've ever been. Yeah. And we got,
we got our 10% back at the end of the, at the end of the documentary,
we just, we sat at a table and we'd discuss why we did it and why I did what,
and then we both understand each other's points.
Like I understood why he needed to know which I hadn't ever really
grasped. Um, and he understood why I didn't tell him.
And then we had a hug of the end of it. I mean, it was,
it was an amazing moment in the studio and because we're identical
twins, we finished, we wrapped up, we said, thank you very much.
We went to the pub and I said, we're good. He went, we're good.
And we've never spoken about it again. We told about it, live here.
[inaudible] But these crimes, uh, no, a mother, my mother got a free pass.
She died, lucky her and, um, and the other men,
we don't really know. I mean, a lot of people say, well, let's go and find them.
It's like, you know what? I was 10 years old. I was in a strange man's house.
I don't know his name. I don't know his address. I don't know where he lives.
I don't really know what he looks like because they're all kind of voting to
each other. And they're middle-aged men. I mean, c'mon, and so it's,
um, I've decided that, you know what, my life's is moving forward.
I'm not going to go back. I'm not going to go chasing ghosts. You know,
I'd rather come out here and talk to you guys as difficult as it is and
get people to break the silence, uh, move it forward. And that,
and that's that attacks the Peter files more than going to try and find them.
Yeah. Some nights.
This is interesting because people are going to happen because when people start
coming here. So I went to tell you a story.
So I had the taxi that arrived at my house this morning in London,
in Notting Hill gate at seven o'clock in the morning, his name was Mike.
He drove me and he said, he thought he'd recognize me.
I told him about the documentary. And he said, he'd seen it. So I was like,
well, that's very interesting. And I said, well, tell me, why did you,
why did you watch that movie? And he said,
because I had something similar in my life. And then we started chatting.
We were in the car for half an hour. And then I just said,
do you mind me asking why? And he said, eventually he said, okay, I'll tell you.
I've never told her living soul, but my brother abused me.
And we had this very strong conversation. So 20 minutes in the car,
and then he said, he's going to go home and tell his wife tonight,
killing his wife now. And you just think, you know,
I've just moved that man forward a little bit. And that's what this is about.
[Inaudible] victims today.
No, we do not fill out victims. And we don't think we are survivors.
We're not even like, nearly like that word,
particularly that we are not affected by this. And I think you have a choice.
You can either be it, or you can be evicted for the rest of your life.
If you want, if you say one,
or you could be a survivor and you can try and put it behind you do some therapy
or you talk to some people and just be neither of those things.
And you can just say, you know what, I'm Marcus Lewis I'm me.
And what happened in my past doesn't shape my future.
[Inaudible].